great ray you have been a true pioneer
and articulating positive vision of the
future in your writing so if you pick
the one that you're most excited about
now what would that are you imagine
going back 10,000 years and asking a
quintessential cave man and woman he
woke what is a beneficial future what
would you like to see and they would say
well it's like this fire to stop going
out and like a bigger bolder to prevent
the animals from getting in the cave
anything else well no I think that would
be pretty perfect
don't you want a better website and apps
and search engines and imagine going
back two million years ago and talking
to primates if you could do that it's
saying isn't great the frontal cortex is
coming and you have additional neocortex
and the higher hierarchy and they say
well what's the point of that and say
well you'll have music and and humor and
the answer would be
what's music what's what's humor so they
couldn't imagine concepts that they
couldn't imagine and by analogy I think
we will have new phenomena that are as
profound as music in humor you could
call it more profound music and and will
be funnier but I think it'll be as
profound as these great leaps that
evolution has brought us because we will
become profoundly smarter and you know
if music and humor are up here and we go
to even higher levels of the neocortex
we're going to have more profound ways
of expressing as though once we have
that we would not want to go back